So things that can go wrong when
you're outsourcing your job is
low quality of work.
It happens a lot of times, you're just
asking someone to do something and
this is not what I asked for,
or this is in such low quality,
how possibly can you think that I
am going to accept this this job?
Another thing is that they charge
you more money than they should.
They said they worked on
this project for 50 hours,
but you know that in it never
took them more than five hours.
What, seriously?
And they can be not responsive,
they're not answering emails,
they're not answering your
instant messages in time.
The slack world is empty and
basically a lot of the stuff that can
happen when you remotely work with
employees, it's not that different.
But it's kind of more annoying.